you said it again
that's james robinson at a press
conference this year dodging snacks that
were being thrown at him by teammates or
facebook i thought that face masks or
something that people i don't know
bags of something james trying to that
that's the ultimate obstacle course
you're trying to answer questions and
people are throwing things at you well
hopefully james nobody be throwing
anything at you today while you talk to
us welcome to the program and
congratulations on a spectacular rookie
season the brightest spot by far for the
jaguars in 2020. uh welcome and how's
everything
thank you for having me uh everything's
going good
when did you know that you were going to
be the guy i remember after leonard
fournette was let go by the jaguars
everybody's trying to figure out who's
the guy gonna be and it became obvious
week one this rookie from illinois state
who wasn't drafted is going to be the
guy and you grabbed that job from week
one and you didn't let go
um i found out uh probably the week
before the game uh
jake kind of just came up to me while we
had a walk through i was like um did you
think you would be running out on first
down i guess then they have the coats
and then i was like i didn't kind of
like say anything and just
lapped it off and then i just started
rolling with the ones
and then i was just like okay maybe i'm
starting
and how did you pull this off because
one of the things we talked about
through the entire season because of the
pandemic no off-season training program
no opportunity for an undrafted guy to
come in and make an impression no
preseason games where an undrafted guy
can get on the field and show the
coaches what he can do what did you do
with limited opportunities to get the
attention of jay gruden the offensive
coordinator and the coaching staff
to to give them the faith that you could
do it
when i came in
i just my mindset was just make the most
out of my opportunity every time i got
one on offense and try to make a big
play and i felt like i was doing that
most of training camp
and then with the 101s and everything um
showing them i can block catch and
everything like that and i feel like
everything that i did just kind of
opened their eyes a little bit and then
it was kind of okay maybe this guy can
play and then
start rolling with the ones and i'm not
sure what their conversation was but
sure they were good
you you obviously impressed them i mean
there's no doubt about that i just as
you as a rookie like could you tell that
maybe
there was they had fallen out of love
with leonard fournette like how shocked
were you when they actually cut him did
you see it coming at all
uh no i don't think anyone saw it coming
we were kind of just all just chilling
in um rooms waiting for meetings and
everything and then we found out but uh
yeah it just kind of was kind of
surprising because i mean he was
practicing with us and
as a rookie you don't really
know how things like that go you don't
think uh the guy's only really
practicing and then just gets gets cut
a guy like that gets cut but i mean
i think
we couldn't really tell what was going
on he was in practice he was just
learning from that i mean just
practicing well doing everything he can
so
this was surprising though
mike mike i i'm gonna ask one more just
real quick i'm always interested with
like the small school guys you didn't
get drafted i don't know how the hell
that didn't happen illinois state people
like oh can this guy play in the nfl
what's gonna happen when he gets in
there
i want two things
what was tougher about the nfl than you
expected what was easier about the nfl
than you expected don't be bashful now
come on give us the truth
um
a tough thing was
probably the speed for me
um i mean coming out i didn't have a
good 40 but uh
i say with the speed and then i think
the easiest thing was just for me it was
picking up the offense uh i studied it
along like before i got to jacksonville
i was just studying the whole playbook
and i kind of caught on to it pretty
well
so i think those two were
main things
james how much motivation did you take
from the fact that you weren't drafted
did that help give you the kick that you
needed to go into camp and and impress
the coaching staff the way you did
um yeah uh
i wouldn't say that motivated me it was
just more of towards the end of the
draft when i knew it probably wasn't
gonna happen i just i was just like
just getting me on the team and once i
got on the team and once i got there
it's just playing football and there's
no time to sit back and relax at all and
i had to open their eyes somehow and
that was my mindset just going in
most impressive
freakiest guy you saw on a field this
year in your match you can't pick your
own team nobody on your no none of your
buddies but just the guy that you were
sitting on the sideline or playing
against where you just went whoa i had
no idea this guy was like this
um
i would say his product it was pretty
cool watching uh aaron rodgers play when
we went to green bay
that was pretty cool see i knew i liked
you uh we were i knew we were eye to eye
on something there see aaron rodgers
that was easy one yep i knew i liked
this guy mike he's smart he knows
football
well i don't know
he's like
he's the president of the aaron rodgers
fan club so uh yeah he likes anybody
that comes on the show and says they
like aaron rodgers hey how do you like
urban meyer because you got a new coach
i don't know if you've spoken to him yet
or what the buzz is around the the
players but what's your thought on the
guy who's going to be taking over the
team starting this year
um
i'll talk with him a few times uh he was
he seems pretty cool
excited to get to work with all of us
and um
yeah i think all of us are just excited
to have him and
see what he brings
to practice his games and all that see
and see what he likes to do
urban i mean it seems like trevor
lawrence is coming to town can you feel
the excitement in jacksonville are
people already starting to clamor about
the clemson quarterback
um i haven't really talked to anyone
about that but um
we're excited whoever comes here to get
to work with them hopefully they can
help us out
do you uh do you talk much to gardner
minchu about what's going on because
he's the guy who was the guy it's got to
be awkward for him it's got to be
awkward for everybody because you
develop an attachment to your teammate
and now they're going to bring in trevor
lawrence by all appearances what's kind
of the conversation what's the buzz as
it relates to gardner's status with the
team
um
i mean i haven't talked to him about
that uh
he seems normal to me uh we actually saw
him yesterday and seemed pretty
he seemed fine to me and we were talking
about getting together and throwing
around and stuff so that's about it
where's the like the biggest adjustment
james robinson wants to make like in the
nfl you know as far as the running back
position what's the one thing you want
to you know improve on this off season
for your own game
um
for me my big thing is uh speed
so i'm going to be working on that a lot
and just getting better at the things
that my already think i'm good at
um
offensive rookie of the year
justin herbert has essentially been
handed the award by people who pay
attention to football but you can make a
strong argument that what you did
undrafted on a team that won one game
was more impressive than what justin
herbert did
are you kind of hoping you get some
votes are you paying attention to that
or you just accept the fact that it's a
quarterback award it's a quarterback
league they're not going to give it to
me
um right now i would say it's hard not
to
pay attention to it
but i try to zone it out too as well but
um
i just
i know people are voting for me my mom
sits and votes she's sitting voting all
the time when she has nothing to do
but um yeah
it is pretty cool just being on that
list with those guys and
i can i can't control who who wins so i
mean
yeah i don't really think about it that
much
all right last one i'm gonna let you go
here i mean we know like derek henry's
awesome but like for james robinson
who's who's who's the running back you
love watching in the nfl right now who's
your favorite
right now yeah right now i like to watch
uh bear henry and derrick henry end out
good boy and apple camera yeah i thought
you might say dalvin cook you guys have
a similar running style i mean derek
henry i i don't think you're gonna grow
another foot this off season so i don't
know if you'll be able to run like him
hey james congratulations on your
success and we wish you all the best
going forward it's fun to watch you
shine as a rookie and we can't wait to
see what you do in 2021 uh thanks for
some of your time we hope to talk to you
again soon thank you good luck james
kick butt man
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports